we have a guest on the phone right now
Patrick Ewing Knicks Hall of Famer ah oh
my god I cannot believe you put me on
blast we have but hold on let me ask you
a question are you more upset at me for
putting you on blast or John and Charles
for letting Michael out of that
double-team in the corner take us back
in the day because even before our
rivalry Indiana versus the Knicks you
guys was the Xavier McDaniel and those
Knicks teams had some unbelievable
rivalries with Michael and the Bulls oh
definitely I mean they're the team
everybody was trying to be you know
after after they were able to get past
Detroit then you know they were the team
everybody was trying to beat they're the
they're the big kids on the block you
know they had you know the greatest
player to play in our era on the team
they had a great supporting cast and you
know we were trying to get where they
where they work you know it's
interesting because you talked about
Michael
he was a part of dream team one the
greatest team ever dissembled we had
Larry jailbird and John Stockton on
can you talk can you walk us through how
every day on the bus going to practices
games airplanes what was it like to be a
part because you guys were rock stars in
Barcelona oh it was it was it was and it
was phenomenal I mean first of all you
have Charles
mr. jokester you know he kept everybody
you know you know just lighten the mood
he's cracking jokes on everybody
you know then you know when we travel
everywhere we're like The Beatles
Michael Jackson you name the big
entertainment you know ever does that
was us everywhere we traveled you know
people were flocking to come see us
you know or touch us it was just it was
a it was a great experience on this team
and you can you can talk about this team
or in general who was the biggest trash
talker Michael Jordan or Larry Bird and
I'm gonna name them one two I mean
they're right up there equal you know
but the difference is at that's the way
by then
hilarious back was messed up so he
wasn't able to perform the way that he
normally does but he still he still had
the mouth it was no shutting him up you
know I think that's that's the reason
why he and I got so close he used to
talk so much trash to me that you know I
could do nothing but the joy how was
those matchups we're talking with
Patrick Ewing on the Dan Patrick show
the matchups in the middle between you
and the Admiral David Robinson oh there
were some great matchups you know Dave
and I you know we're kind of in some
respect remarried image you know he's
left-handed I'm right-handed but you
know we both have to like he's a little
bit more athletic than I and then I was
we could both shoot the jump shot we
could both put it on the floor we were
both great shot blockers so you know we
were very dominant you know if you look
at our two were very dominant in the
middle you know yet he and I in a matter
of fact shoot the whole practice you
know the practice were bet it was much
it was a hundred percent better than the
games you know you had he and I battling
against each other yet Karl and Charles
battle against each other
flying going against NJ Flyers
yeah well you know that was all magic
you know that's another trash-talking
guy you imagine
oh man yeah you forgot magic you know
magic he was a big man on the block you
know before Matt you know Michael came
along so I mean you had these guys who
not only could would talk smack but also
back it up is you know not a lot of
people can do that it is the age of the
big man a dinosaur is it done is you see
the NBA now everything is being
stretched to the three-point line the
back to the basket David Robinson
Patrick Ewing Hakeem Olajuwon Rik Smits
those days are they gone I don't think
they're gone I just think that you're
there's not anybody around right now
that that's willing to play that way I
think once somebody else maybe one of
these young guys okay a big young guys
that come in who just came in you know
might decide to try to you know go back
to do it there's nothing wrong with you
know being able to score on the block
you know you know some some people like
Michael would tell me one day that you
know he's doubt that you know I couldn't
play in this era I told her I said if I
was playing in this era I'd be Michael
Jordan because you know the thing is one
I could shoot I could post up I could I
defend you know I wasn't no I wasn't a
one-way player I played both ways and
then I would be surrounded with all
these shooting that didn't the double
when the double came I'll either kick it
out in the double don't come who do they
have to stop me well a big fella you're
right no one's gonna stop you in today's
game because the big guys are much more
softer than they were back then when we
played but I appreciate your question I
do that I don't think is I just think
everything goes around and you know is
fickle it's cyclical circle goes around
the circle they'll come back well I
appreciate you calling in look I wasn't
trying to throw you underneath the bus
I'm throwing oak in and John Starks Road
we're letting him out of the double-team
because you were doing your job
protecting the rim those two
his job was to get him in that
double-team yes it was well you know
what that's it that's the price you pay
to be a shot blocker there sometimes
sometimes you're gonna get dumped on and
sometimes you're gonna block it but I do
have to say that I block more than I got
dumped on Patrick Ewing one of the best
shot blockers players for the New York
next we appreciate it
oh my pleasure ready to keep on though
you're doing a good job man keep it up
thank you I appreciate it
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience